for the past two months not a single
shot was fired in what was termed
Nigeria's Wild West
no one was kidnapped for ransom in no
livestock was stolen village chief
Abdullah Abu Bakr and his constituents
are back from 18 months of self-imposed
exile hunted down by bandits and
vigilantes he and people in this village
and now enjoying what they say are the
best moments of their lives in two years
a return to normalcy yeah we were on the
run from law enforcement bandits and
vigilantes for more than a year and a
half as small as this village is it lost
10 people and the raids many have been
kidnapped including women and children a
thousand cattle and sheep was stolen
from us two months ago they returned
home and are trying to rebuild their
lives for eight years bandits mainly
from nomadic herdsmen terrorized and
sacked entire villages in Northwest
Nigeria local vigilantes formed to
protect communities became the law the
resulting violence killed more than
4,000 people and displaced tens of
thousands the state government says it's
moving to address what the nomads called
decades of exploitation and oppression
by providing water roads and other
services it's also disbanding the
militias that have been accused of
killing felonies and denying them access
to basic services the truth is holding
for now a few months ago driving along
this highway would have been extremely
dangerous even for the security forces
but now a decent number of vehicles use
the road killings and abductions used to
happen here almost every day so for most
people the relative peace they now enjoy
seems and feels almost unreal
and it's not only the displace to a
happy with the turn of events in Sephora
the police have been targeted in the
mayhem say they realized that the force
of arms cannot end the violence all
along having a military or security
actions in these states but as far as
I'm concerned as much work for it has
not achieved appreciable progress in
terms of decapitating the defenders so I
came with an idea of having a way of
resolving this issue that is using
dialogue that started paying off several
assault rifles and rocket blow
intercepted surrounded by the gunmen and
soon the police say hundreds boy I
expected they say there never was a will
to resolve the conflict in zone 4 a
state until recently I discovered a
default code Authority dent we are no
zeros on the matter
they have another idea so I have to
leave but now the current administration
the FF lien is somebody who towards
their line their language group conflict
resolution through dialogue but there
are concerns of the truth won't hold for
long and whether an amnesty will not
embolden other girls to take up arms
against citizens and the state for now
Abdullah Abu Bakr and the people in this
village I enjoying this newly found
peace and despite their losses some of
them can even afford to smile al Jazeera
Dogon where Northwest Nigeria